lawmakers and activists are exploring
new ways to treat substance abuse as the
opioid crisis sweeps across this country
a world-class athlete is developing an
unconventional approach you could say in
Wyoming by taking addicts outdoors Jeff
Glor discovered how exposing people to
the elements could actually help them
recover Jeff good morning Gail good
morning to Jackson Hole Wyoming is one
of the most exclusive resort locations
in the world it is a destination for
extreme wealth and extreme athletes the
combination of skiing climbing and
hiking might be unparalleled but the
highs that come from adventure sports
often lead thrill-seekers to crave the
same rush off the mountain that's where
the problem and perhaps the solution
starts these are 40 pounds of piece nice
yeah it's an unusual approach to an
agonising issue by putting people's
hearts under extreme pressure
Ryan Burke believes he can retrain their
brain this is not coddling no outpatient
or kind of addiction therapy in the past
has been a lot of talk you know a lot of
let's just sit around in a circle and
chat about that which is important but
it's more important to go out there and
practice that skill under pressure do
you know what the body feels like and to
know what you're capable of dealing with
Burke is a world-class endurance athlete
who holds several mountain triathlon
records but he's not interested in
sponsors or endorsement deals
pause breathe through Pete so when you
feel yourself getting all worked up take
a second he's dedicated his career to
addiction counseling pioneering an
approach called mind strength it's a
mental fitness program that pairs
athletes and addicts in the attempt to
get them to stay calm under pressure it
works and kind of put them under
simulated exposure so they know what
fear feels like so when the time hits
when their life's actually on the line
whether it's a wilderness or a wild
party begging kind of staying control oh
good you're just gonna start climbing
the man about to climb a rock wall while
wearing a blindfold is Andrew shorts a
client of Burke's he grew up in Jackson
and was a world-class skier by the age
of 17 before his burgeoning career
suddenly went off track the skiing
culture does encourage people to
basically that the phrases too
harder to go home and that came from
skiing and sort of transitioned to my
partying and my drinking and drug use it
was alcohol for you it was opioids it
was heroin a lot of people don't come
back from that
absolutely it's interesting it's a very
smooth transition as radical as it
sounds talking about it now you know a
couple years later but it you don't
realize what's going on until you're
kind of in the thick of it until you do
take the step back and say you know a
year ago is doing this and now I'm here
so you're gonna move over to your right
now shorts if you can like right on the
wall now three years sober
Andrews shorts is making his way back to
competition with Berks help mine
strength does things like send people
into bitingly cold lake water three two
one
ask them to hold their breath and tie a
climbers not under water recovering
addicts also joined partner athletes to
run blindfolded balance on a ball and
problem solved with a highly elevated
heart rate try solve this question
routines informed by Burke's own life
experience you saw yourself at one point
going down this road and you were able
to pull yourself out of it
yeah when I started to see the challenge
of me I'd say over drinking you know
abusing on the cusp of addiction I was
on the border of having a very big
problem I pulled myself back and the
mountains help me do that
meditation is in other part of the
program too of Burke's favorite sayings
are slower is faster and patience is
progress whether you're working at a
desk in New York or down in Florida on
the beach we all have an overactive mind
and the ability to slow that mind down
is beneficial for everyone it's
interesting you're teaching people not
to think yeah yeah yeah absolutely
just chill yeah quiet the brain I use an
ocean analogy is that everyone's on the
surface and the waves are really big you
have conflict in your life but there's a
quiet part of your brain you know that
part beneath the surface has even 510
feet deep that wants to be calm and so
to bring people of that level
makes for a higher quality human being I
think Burke has lost friends and clients
to overdoses which have more than
tripled in Wyoming since 2005 the people
we talked to say attitudes though have
shifted and a problem that was once
ignored is now being discussed widely
that's a very interesting fact that he
has unlike that patience is progress no
I like flowers faster we all wrote that
down patience is probably like him quiet
and quieting the brain and it seems to
work it does seem to work and it had a
purpose and planning yeah and it looked
like you were sitting in a painting I
have to say it's great I mean not much
is better than the American West and in
particular Jack's accent right